so when I talk about strategic ideas
when I do the main idea is not
necessarily to talk about tactics so
there shouldn't be any you know white to
play and win aqueous or made in three
however you need to understand tactics
so your ideas work so you may have a
piece somewhere and you want to move it
somewhere else
it might take two or three moves but
while you're doing that you're
blundering like every other piece on the
board because you're not paying
attention to that and that's why Karpov
is so good and karpas been to our club
before and he was the world chess
champion for ten years and you've all
heard of him right yay Karpov
doing the hawk harpa terrible Karpov was
well known for having great strategic
ideas taking positions that look equal
or boring and slowly improving and then
getting a winning position now we'll do
a little history of chess to understand
what rity jig ideas are in the 1800's
you had famous players like Paul Morphy
yay and in those days you know you
sacrificed all your pieces and you
played for made and not only did you
sacrifice all your pieces your opponent
was supposed to take them like if you
didn't take somebody's piece sacrifice
what's wrong with you yeah you got to
take that and either they mated you or
they didn't you were up for pieces
that's how chess was played in 1800s
then there was a guy named Wilhelm Stein
it's who you've also all heard of he
supposed to okay and steinitz was the
first official world champion and
Steinitz also played like a lunatic and
some of his greatest games are really
interesting and then at some point he
said wait a minute I could get a space
advantage and control the center and
castle and have a safer King and have
better development and eventually I'll
win because I have a lot of
little advantages and when I talk about
strategy and strategic ideas I talk
about little advantages like you control
a square your Bishop is better your
knight is better give a better center
you have less isolated pawns your King
is safer and Steinitz would say if you
have a lot of little advantages then you
win because you have a winning position
and after Steinitz that's basically the
way chess has been at the top level if
you watch a game and some guy wins a
pawn or winds two pawns and there's no
compensation they just win the game is
just over now it's a junior championship
some of the games are very suspicious so
somebody come in material and still lose
because these aren't the best players in
the world now the game I want to show
you today is Karpov comm scheme for 1992
and it's one of my favorite games
because Karpov does something that's
very rare he gets a big advantage on one
side of the board and you're all
thinking you know win win win and Karpov
doesn't do that he says okay I'm winning
over here
now we're gonna play over here and then
he wins over there and then he plays
over there and he's winning everywhere
and his opponent can't move and so this
is why this is one of my favorite games
because he slowly improves this position
and the other reason I like the game is
the person that he's playing that's what
he does also so it's very impressive to
beat somebody at their own game
and I'm sure all of you have heard of
gotta calm ski so some know nobody's
heard of gotta calm ski
yeah he's US Champion every year that
helps in this club now just reigning
champion just won yeah there you go and
also he played a World Championship
match with Anatoly Karpov who won that
match
Karpov because cops he's ever been world
champion now that was a weird match that
was when Kasparov and fita were arguing
and stuff so either that managed in
really count Kasparov was world champion
okay so this game started if this
buttons work okay D for
and we have a king's indian or Grunfeld
Karpov played g3 which is very rare for
him
normally Karpov is playing classical
Sicilian with Knights e3 and e4 and well
Tomsky did something he also doesn't do
very often one of the things I noticed
about the top players is they play
everything they're good at every opening
and they study all of them and then if
they get tricked into one or the other
they still have some some stuff going on
and he played c6 which is not what calm
ski normally does in this position
normally calm secluded play a grünfeld
by something like castles bishop not
Bishop h3 terrible way once you go into
h3 I'd have to do this okay and then
then maybe d5 or d6
okay d5 and this is a common Grenfell
position that I would expect Tomsky to
have and if you play in our Chess Club
on a regular basis you may know one of
our club members Matthew Larson very
tall very skinny and he's rated about
2030 2040 and he likes to play this
position with with the black pieces the
grid felled
now instead gada played c6 and because
he played c6 he's preparing to play d5
and that's something that we should
probably talk about for an hour because
I get paid by the hour
right-oh learned that when you're an
adult that's important okay or watch
Arrested Development and learn how they
charge by the hour the lawyer is pretty
funny actually so one of the things I do
that you guys never do not that I'm
insulting all of you but what I do it
all the time and you guys rarely do it
is I make preparatory moves I want to
make a move but I can't make it so
instead of giving up or making it anyway
in losing I prepare to make it so you go
to the store and you buy chicken right
Ben okay I don't got a vegetarian but
and you buy chicken it's frozen you take
it home and start eating it
or do you do something first something
okay and that's called preparing you
have to prepare the chicken so you can
eat it otherwise you won't live very
long okay
and so Tomsky wants to play d5 but he
wants to take back with a pawn which is
what happens and a lot of openings in
chests like the caro-kann the French
defense those are all your favorite
openings right you've heard of them
right
again those are preparatory moves I'll
move one you're going to play d5 I'll
move to what you're preparing it
so c6 black wants to play d5 but he
wants to protected by upon and that's
what happened okay and Karpov takes
because Karpov likes really simple
positions with a simple plan and Karpov
is worried if he doesn't take he'll have
to learn some complicated variation
where black takes on c4 and he
sacrifices upon for a couple of moves
Karpov thinks if I have a symmetrical
position and it's my turn to move I have
the advantage make sense so he gets a
symmetrical position and again a lot of
my students would probably raise their
hand and say well I want to capture with
a queen or the knight on d5 you could
capture the queen of the night but then
you're going to start moving the same
piece many times for example if you
capture with a queen no not there okay
which one of these do I want new
variation then when your Queens attack
you're going to start moving your queen
again and you're getting rid of the
control of the center why it's going to
have pawns in the center and you're not
also you didn't play c6 so you could not
take back with the C pawn that's why you
played c6 you want this pawn in the
center okay that's what you want not off
the board you want it in the center and
of course this position symmetrical so
it's pretty close to equal Knight c3
castles 95 white is avoiding castling so
he can do stuff in the center first like
he's putting pressure on the D pawn by
moving his knight out of the way and
he's making it hard
black to develop his pieces it's not
clear actually how black should develop
for example if black plays Knight c6
which he did not play looks like a
normal sort of move
he might be worried that this pawn is
going to be weak and that White's going
to attack it by putting his rook on the
open file using his queen or making sure
the pawn can never move by putting his
knight in front of it and now black has
this isolated pawn and this is called
what kind of pawn is this call we have a
name for that backward pawn right or C
pawn again so that ruins black's pawn
structure a little bit okay
so cons key has a really good idea
instead of trading this night for this
night he's going to trade this Knight
then his Bishop will be wide open but he
can't move this night because then his D
pawn is hanging this pawn needs
protection okay and this is the
strategic idea how do we protect our
pawn so we can move our Knight away and
get rid of that invading Knight
how do we protect this fun move the King
pawn on e6 same answer right and he
played a six now every move in chess is
good and bad okay sort of like you
you're a good person but you know I know
Ben pretty well so you know bad - you
know watch it right stole my name I had
it first okay now it's good because
we're protecting the center the center
is good it's bad because it makes our
bishop not so happy bishops not happy so
what to fix that later
castles Knight ft7 now his bishop is
open and he's kicking out the invading
Knight now Karpov doesn't want to get
kicked out and he doesn't want to trade
that beautiful night for the knight
that's way back there so how does he
protect his knight protect our Knight
oops terrible correct f4 now White has
more space White has this beautiful
night here
and if black trades the nights and white
gets a pawn there then White's going to
have control of this square d6 maybe his
Knights going to come in so black
doesn't want to do that
he plays knight c6 now he's not so
worried that White's going to take this
night like he was the last time because
his night is already protecting c5 he's
going to play C 5 really quickly so he's
not as scared Karpov played Bishop e3
getting his last minor piece out and
defending his pawn on on III on d4 now
you were taught by somebody or you
weren't should have been that you
shouldn't put pieces in front of your
center pawns okay you have two Center
blinds you put a bishop or a knight in
front of them they can't move so what's
Karpov doing what's wrong with him
well Karpov put his Bishop there
temporarily okay he doesn't like this
square for his bishop that hangs the D
pawn he doesn't like this square for his
bishop he can't jump over his pawn so
he's doing what's called a maneuver
normally in chess you would move your
Knights your Knights here and you want
it somewhere else
in chess you can also maneuver your
bishops a little more rare because
bishops usually can go into one turn
this Bishop is going to go back either
here or here and then the e pawn is
going to move forward and we have our D
pawn defended by the bishop so that's
actually a good defensive piece Knight
b6 chomsky likes this e4 square bishop
f2 as I espoused and Bishop g7 so unlike
most of you these guys develop their
pieces in castle I wish I get said about
the juniors I'll watch the junior games
and the lying I don't know it's move 20
and the pieces are still on the back row
I don't know how they do that
you watch super grandmasters play all
their bishops are out all their Knights
are out and they've castled and
calm ski wants to put his work on the
open line and calm skis is why this
ships not so good here it's blocked by
my pawns so if you take that Bishop that
means you wasted all your moves with you
night night here night here Knight takes
bishop and now black doesn't have that
bad bishop so car pop plays efore
playing in the center looks good and
well whites going to win upon next move
so there's two things why I can do he
could take the pawn obviously or he can
defend this pawn the problem with taking
the pawn is this Knights really good on
e4 it's going to d6 it's going to c5 and
White's moving forward with his pieces
and well maybe I would have done that
because I'm not as good as calm ski but
consti defended his Center pawn he wants
to keep his pawn in the center how did
he do that
also I'm do this from memory from 20
years ago hope we did the move I said he
made who knows right 90 that's my
recollection he played 97 I don't know
that looked at this game in 1993 so it's
been 20 years okay
97 was played hooray and now we got a
good defense here of the center pawn and
our Bishop has a lot more squares now
Karpov did something if I remember
correctly that I would usually advise
against but he had a good reason most
super grandmasters they like bishops
better than Knights and generally the
lower rage you are the more you like
Knights because your forking your
opponent's pieces with the knight
they're like ah don't you're super grim
missed your post I'll fall for that
anymore now you like bishops more
because bishops can move really fast
my bishops are over here I can go other
side of the board in one move if I have
a knight I'm hopping around slow I can't
get there so grandmasters like bishops
grandmasters also like space now lower
rated players like yourselves you like
to take three pieces you're like I'm a
piece up I'm two pieces up I'm three
pieces of you know you're winning right
these guys don't do
it'll give their pieces away she has to
get other advantages that's why it's an
ideas class and idea that good players
like like ya sir Sara Juan who's the
Grandmaster residents who does the
commentary with me he loves space spaces
his favorite
he had space so he can move his pieces
and you have no space okay
so if I'm sitting in the middle of the
room I can go wherever I want but if I'm
standing over here then I'm trapped and
I don't have anywhere to go
same thing in chess if you move forward
you have all that space to move your
pieces and your opponent gets more and
more cramped so Karpov he did a
two-for-one he got two bishops and he
got more space so you guys like to be
two pieces up he likes to bishops and
more space he likes different things
than you do and he played nine takes d7
and what was his follow-up be five so he
says I have more space than you and I
have more bishops than you this bishop
here is particularly suspicious okay
Chomsky plays wrote to c8
putting the rook on the open line seems
sort of normal rook to c1 challenging
the open line again normal and then cos
he plays a six Khan ski is stopping this
Knight from ever going to d6 and he's
preparing to play b5 and B for later
attacking on the Queen side b3 and again
when you see this pawn and this pawn and
this point you might be thinking King
side attack and you are correct when you
have a space advantage you want to
eventually go forward but Karpov he
doesn't just like to beat you and do
what he wants to do he wants to stop you
from doing what you want to do and he's
as well this night on b6 someday it's
going to move forward and car bombs like
that could be her that could harass me a
little bit so I'm going to play b3 and
now that I not b6 looks pretty stupid
it can't go to a4 can't go to c4 we're
going to go it can go to a a
now maybe he'll go there later so carbot
is like look you're not doing anything
and once you don't do anything then I'll
beat you so Karpov this is the one thing
I learned when I work with Gregory
Cardinal 1993-1994 when I de san furred
fellowship and I got to work with
somebody he said don't always think
about what you want to do think about
stopping your opponent from what they
want to do this is a big issue with the
junior players yes so share ones always
sitting here saying this is the long
term plan for Y and then the kid
sacrifices all his pieces because he
wants to give me right away and he wants
to calculate some long variation and
sometimes they're right and sometimes
they're wrong and yesterday wasn't he
just slowly build his position as
opponent can't move and the juniors
don't want to do that but you should
want to do that you should want to stop
your opponent but okay calm skis pretty
good rook c7 what's his next move
double off he's going to play here and
take advantage of the knight on c3 Queen
d2 protecting the knight and rook c8
obviously so this is a great game for
this for this lecture for this class
because now we get to see what Karpov
was such a good player because what he
does is he does what he wants to do
which is to advance on the Kings side
where he has more space at the same time
he stops his opponent from what they
want to do
he plays g4 which is anybody who wants
to check me black
they will play g4 Bishop to f8 why did
black play Bishop to f8 was his bishop
good on g7 not really working that
bishop on FA Khan that other diagonal
what's a good square this Bishop a3
right and b4 lots of good squares all
kinds of good squares so calm skis like
me I want my bishop to go here and calm
ski is a good idea he saw that this
Knight was weakened by b3 when this pawn
was on beat so I was I was solid
so when white puts his pawns on
squares that means they're not defending
the dark squares white spawns are on
dark squares in the middle so this
Bishop on g7 really isn't doing anything
here so calm Sookie plays Bishop f8
Karpov plays Queen III he doesn't want
Bishop b4 to pin his knight even if it's
illegal he doesn't want it to happen and
this is why the world champion Tigran
Potosi on or for you Americans Petrosian
this is why he was so good he knew what
you wanted to do before you you wanted
to do it so he knows Chomsky is going to
get his Bishop over here so he's getting
his Queen out of the way and knight c6
obviously this bishop is going to start
harassing f5 hurray attack Bishop to a3
as advertised attacking the rook on on
c1 rook to d1 well rook c2 might look
normal but then what do you do after
Knight be 400 and again one of the
things that's important strategies
important playing the right ideas is
important but you have to see the
tactics along with the strategy if the
guys attacking all of your pieces and
you can't save them that your strategy
didn't work so he gets out of this pin
by playing work to D 1 calm ski plays
Knight before anyway obviously attacking
the knight discovered attack Queen h6
what scar pawns next to move pawn f6 and
then White has the advantage now when
you're playing in the Chess Club here
some of your opponent's might play rook
takes Knight f6 and then you win that
could happen especially in a blitz game
but at the world championship level
those guys don't make it so easy I hate
those guys in black played Queen eight
so if white played f6 Queen FA
and now your knight on c3 is hanging so
you can't retreat your queen you're
going to lose your knight and you don't
want to trade Queens because then you're
not going to meet him anymore
now black dominates on the C file and
this is a tack when the knight moves
away so I can't do any of that and this
is the kind of thing I see lorded
players do a lot they make a threat f6
you stop the threat Queen FA that
they're like alright now what do I do
okay and you can't do that you have to
see what your opponent's going to do
obviously the Knights attacked so Karpov
played Knight be one attacking the
bishop on a3 that's not good
lose your bishop so this should be two
obviously again f6 doesn't work just
Queen f8 and it's funny my my my
colleague Gregory katana was just got
inducted into the Hall of Fame this year
the u.s. Hall of Fame across the street
your favorite Grandmaster from what
state he's your favorite Grandmaster wow
I mean what state the last 25 years
Kansas it does start with a K so that's
close as far as I know Kansas has no
grandmasters I'll be corrected by
somebody from Kansas
the Kentucky yay he's the Lexington lion
or the lion from Lexington I don't know
one oh and chitin oov showed me this
game before anybody else did and he was
really impressed with car buffs play
when when Qaeda not was white he kept
the analyzing sac sacrifice play for me
and Karpov always surprised him that was
the first surprising move Queen to d2
didn't that Queen look pretty impressive
over here on h6 looked like mating was
coming but Karpov he's like ooh I like
all these pieces over here I'm going to
take some of those you don't want to
lose your pieces do you cops he doesn't
lose pieces 9c2
saved all his pieces but when you play
Knight c2
it's really hard to play rook situ it's
hard to do it
so now blacks counter play is stopped he
was going to play rook c2 and he was
going to infiltrate and now he can't do
that
so Karpov is happy king h1
why did Karpov play king h1 he wants his
rook to be really active on the F file
well what's blocking his rook bishop
well he can move his bishop away the
problem is if the bishop goes to a
normal square let's say h4 now nothing's
protecting this pawn bishop takes pawn
Shack Knight takes pawn so car bombs
like hanging how do I move my bishop but
save my pawn this is why its strategic
ideas well he wants to go to g1 but
there's something on g1 so he moves it
away King G what King h1 now he's going
to play bishop g1 his King looks pretty
safe right and the rook on f1 is now on
the open F file and he's like well
what's comps he going to do I stop all
the counter play Queen e7 this of g1 as
advertised
Knight to d7 getting his Knight back
into the game supposedly rook f3 playing
for mate
Queen B 4 does white want to trade
Queens not wise playing for me black
would love a queen trade then is rooks
will come on the C file Queen h6 what's
White's next move rook h3 looks pretty
good so black plays Queen f8 does white
want to trade Queens
no Queen g5 now because the queen is on
FA White's threatening F takes G 6
winning immediately not a good square
for the Queen on f8 so calm ski fee and
kettle's is queen if I remember from 20
years ago yep okay
Queen g7 and now this Queen is trapped I
mean okay h8 but that's crazy
Queen F ain't allows f take C 6 again
you can't put your Queen on the file at
this ruck
so now Karpov goes back with his Queen
to d2 and says aha your Queens trapped
and your Queen side pieces are also
trapped
you can't move anything and Karpov is
going to slowly build up his attack rook
F 1 H 4 and so forth blacks got to do
something
he's losing on the Kings side and his
Queen side pieces are all attacked so
calm ski is tricky b6 defending the a5
square because he wants to play a 5 and
the Knights of B for rook f1 doubling
rooks a 5 as suggested h4 so Karpov goes
about his way
I'm gonna checkmate you and now Khan ski
shows his idea he sacrifices a piece
because he doesn't think white can take
it Knight to be four can white take that
bishop let's analyze it what would you
do with black - right there yeah now
White's queen is a little iffy right
that calm ski is pretty tricky if the
Queen moves somewhere that's Queen's
trapped
so the Karpov trap is own Queen we have
a commercial and then we come back no no
commercial ok
this isn't regular TV so so black wants
to play rook to c2 and get counter play
sounds good right counter plays good so
he plays instead a3 he says get your
night out of there I don't like that
night there well he doesn't want to go
to see - that's where he came from and
now his Rick can't go to see - so he
played rook c2 Queen f4 would be the
Queen out of the way and now the Knights
attacked Knight to c6 now in your
professional opinion as fine chess
players right Mike who's in domination
of the C file who's got this e-file
black who
at the F file right now Qaeda knov when
he showed me this game and all of you
you're like I got the F file check me
and hope he doesn't get counter-plan the
queenside Karpov said you have the C
file I want the C file that's my file
why do you get to see file so Karpov one
on the kingside you can see on the
kingside who's winning whites crushing
it on the Queen side it looks like
blacks winning blacks got this the C
file dominated fish and car pops like
you can't do that to me I'm Karpov
Karpov says get your get out of the C
file that's my file this should be h3
putting pressure on e6 so calm ski plays
an idea Bishop III controlling the c1
square you'll see why later and rook f2
and Karpov says you know what this
bishops trapped so I'm going to trade
all the rooks off and I'm going to go
take your bishop and this Queen is not
very helpful is it that Queen just
sitting there in front of the king
so carp Barb's ideas rook takes rook
then the other works f2 and we're going
to win that Bishop and we're going to
take the C file very strange idea from
somebody who's winning on the kingside I
don't get it d4 takes takes takes takes
rook F 2 what do you want black to do
here loses rook no loses bishop on b2 no
so he has to take how does he save his
Bishop Bishop a3 and now Queen c2 now
who has the C file right why does the C
file black's bishop is trapped white's
winning on the Kings side with all his
pawns up there and White's threatening
to win a night either Queen move wins
the night now when somebody is beating
you strategically and there's nothing
you can do well if you're calm ski
there's always something you can do calm
seas US Champion several times konkey
played for the world
championship cons he's currently number
11 in the world probably better when
this game was played so he realized
things weren't going well White has more
space White has two bishops this Bishop
is trapped on the side and White's about
to attack two pieces so calm ski wasn't
feeling it now he was feeling like I'm
going to lose but he played the
trickiest moves possible Knight takes e5
and now there's some people in this room
we won't say who they are they're always
playing tricky they're playing tricky
I'll move one move to move three and you
guys are like eyes too tricky to give
all your pieces away and your opponent's
ten pieces up okay
at the top level when you play tricky
but it doesn't work then your opponent
refutes it you're like ah why'd I do
that and we have examples of those
players more as a [ __ ] shear of
occasional Yvon truck playing like crazy
chests and then losing three or four
games in a row well calm ski played
crazy because he had a losing position
and he thought crazy was his best chance
okay so he sacrificed tonight but now
black has all kinds of threats Queen
takes bishop pawns hanging this white
King is exposed so he had somebody
okay Karpov he said give me that night
that night on e eight Queen Shaq Queen
takes Knight Shaq and now it's equal
material but you can't save you a knight
on da this should be to check and now
well White's a piece up but black might
start playing Bishop e5 check that looks
pretty dangerous then the Queen and
Bishop could start an attack on the king
this white bishops not really attacking
blacks King that Bishop sort of trapped
so Karpov got rid of the black Bishop if
you were white you wanted this Bishop to
disappear off the board what would you
do
Karpov made it disappear he's a magician
that's right checked him with a pawn
what did black do one legal move so he
played it and Preston's idea was what
does white do check in with a bishop one
legal move Karpov is going there's one
legal move he can really calculate and
tanks okay now if it's White's turn to
move we got some checkmate stuff going
on here
gee it did but look at this checkmate g5
Bishop f3 Queen f4 mate Tomsky didn't
want to get checkmated so Queen c2
Bishop f3 mate is now illegal he's like
you can't move your bishop check King g3
why King g3 and not King h3 right but
what's the difference between h3 and g3
the bishop could go there anyway because
the Queen's protecting it the difference
somebody said it I don't know who you
yeah yeah if I do this you could trade
Queens check takes and that's a lot of
pawns of deal with anybody could win
Karpov doesn't want to trade Queens
Karpov wants to checkmate his opponent
so King g3 now I'm going to play mate
mates good because then you win well
what it comes to you to stop me now you
playing one more move if I remember
right which I may not and then I go here
check that's tough now he didn't let
that happen he's calm ski
oh yeah that's what I think I think
that's what he did yeah
now with a car poppy trade Queens with
Queen f4 now ridiculous what did he do
to age three and now Queen can go to f5
can it exactly you know and calm ski
gave up man if you saw calm ski here at
the US Championship you think he was the
greatest player ever but then you see
him playing Karpov not equality is good
and if I'm not saying Karpov is a better
player because now he's not now as many
of you know the person Anand beat in the
World Championship last year was
incorrect
Boris Kelvin very good that was another
that was before that was okay that was
because you like Bulgarian chess player
so much that's why you said to Paul
exactly
so Golf and who is a suspicious
challenger to say the least he was the
world he was the Challenger they tied
the match then they had blitz chess or
something in an online okay now
currently there's a tournament going on
in Moscow called anyone you tall
memorial named after who talk right now
tall claimed he was writing about his
chest life he said I'm a better player
now not now but I'm a better player in
my 40s than I was in my 20s could I
understand chance a lot better now of
course his tactical I may have been a
little slower but he on his
understanding of strategical ideas was
good well I played Boris Gelfand back in
the day you don't remember what day that
was because it was many days ago okay
was thousands of days ago this game was
played in 89 or 90 I don't remember
because it was so long ago and Gelfand
was an up-and-coming player he was a top
player but not like now now he's playing
in the tall Memorial Golf and is in
second place
Delphine has two wins and four draws
solid now I played more as golf fan back
of the day and
for the strategic ideas class there's
one very important moment name is Oh
Indian that's not the important part and
like the other players we developed all
of our pieces we must have been good too
and we got this position okay
and it's about equal maybe I'd rather
have white but I was white so I guess
I'd rather have white okay it's about
equal and here black made a crazy
decision and in my opinion I could be
wrong I never asked him actually I feel
I should ask him in my opinion he
thought I'm no good
I can't disagree with him and he's
really good so he's got to mess the game
up a little so I can play really badly
guess it give me a chance this is pretty
boring so it's hard for me to blunder
all my pieces so golf fan was thinking
if I make the game crazy then been
finals going to blunder every move and
I'll win okay but I can't really
disagree with that he's right but he
went a little too crazy and this
actually happened today in the US Junior
Championship but it worked
the guy went too crazy and he's the guy
who's in first place Luke Harmon of
alati your favorite player right then 14
years old and he's the freshman at UCLA
starting in August
okay he showed you guys okay you guys
are like wait I was a freshman at 13
okay no not in middle school in college
okay and he's in the first place of the
junior he's from the great chest state
of Idaho would not agree chest ache but
he's 24 70s so what do I know
so he's 24 17 14 years old freshman at
UCLA clear first to the tournament here
in the US Junior Championship now he
played like a lunatic today and was
completely lost down three pawns for
nothing computer said -8 he's playing
Sarah Chang who's not having a good turn
lowest rated player and she thought her
opponent had threats he did not have she
defended against the fake threats and
allowed real threats and ended up losing
so she wasn't too happy about that and
that was the third game this tournament
where Luke was completely losing in one
so that that's how you win tournaments
okay now he went a little crazy because
he wanted to win and that's what my
opponent it here what's the craziest
move black can play and this is Boris
Gelfand now know even crazier also for
those children in the audience resigns
is not a move and draw offers also not a
move those are my two most common
answers I hear when I'm going to chess
camp I'm like what do I do
resign offer to draw very good Queen
takes e4 like loses on purpose so you're
not doing that castles Queen side okay
now let me ask you this question - black
move these Kings side pawns over here no
good answer - black move his Queen side
pawns he moved all of them so when you
cancel like looking at White's King you
would like to have all the pawns in
front of your King stationary so your
King safe his King is not safe because
he moved all of his pawns so now we're
going to go get him and this is a
strategical idea that you see an
opposite side castling White Castle down
the Kings side black castle on the Queen
side so what kind of storms do we see
pawn storms
unlike the storms here at the st. Louis
truce carrier although I think Boris was
more scared of my storms now if you were
here in 2011 in August I think August is
right might have been July then you will
know that Boris Gelfand lectured this
very Chess Club who was at that lecture
anyone you were there I was not there
because I was in China and India so I
couldn't you didn't do it though I did
negotiate on behalf of the Chess Club to
get him here and the reason he was here
he didn't fly from Israel to say I want
to give a lecture at the Chess Club he
has relatives in Minnesota and insane
Louis he was visiting his relatives he's
like having st. Louis let's go to the
Chess Club so Boris is actually lectured
here but I don't think he showed this
game all right I'll see probably never
knows we're playing me but okay so b4
let's go get them h6 Bishop f4 what's my
bishop attacking d6 now he made the warm
strategical move ever if you made this
soup I'd throw you out of class okay
well not the bigger guys but the small
people I would throw out because I'm
bigger than them okay I'm attacking his
D pawn and he what he should do is move
away his Knight somewhere maybe e5 maybe
f8 and then his rook would defend his
pawn but he played a strategical
atrocity 'if I've horrible well it akaru
say not impressed at all terrible
weakening f5 weakening d5 you don't put
all your pawns on the third-ranked so
you can move into the fourth rank and
undefended all these squares that my
hand is on here they're all protected I
can't go to any of them that's the point
of playing the Hedgehog after he five
terrible weakening the white squares now
he plays for mate I agree and now he
played his last mistake his first
mistake was castling second mistake was
e5 and now he misplaced all of his rooks
he wants to put a hook on the G foul it
should be this rook but he played this
rook to make sure he would have no
control over the center make sure 100%
okay this rook is just trapped terrible
okay so I can't be waiting for him to
meet me because then he will be showing
you this game and I would be winning the
tal memorial so I played a five busting
open the Queen side he's like thanks for
the free pawn and I'm going to have
another that he decided not to have
another if he took I was going to play
b5 and you see how my bishop is backing
up my pawn backed up I'm going to take
if you take my Knights coming in and my
rooks are coming
and this pawn is very iffy and if you
play black here I'm going to really
crush you because your game is really
really really bad terrible he didn't
like any of that so he played even worse
so after c5 he played g4 terrible but
he's already losing my computer said toe
and at that time my computer said
nothing because it was 1989 but now my
computer's like plus everything on my
computer is pretty happy I forked his
Bishop and queen
he took my bishops blocking his rook his
other look I don't know what that's
doing and instead of taking this pawn I
took this pawn here his King now he made
a fifth mistake he traded bishops she
shouldn't do and took my pawn on b4 now
who's King is safer why my kids got
everything in front of it as Kings
terrible and now I played a tactical
motif that wins immediately rooked
paycheck he's got three legal moves
probably queen bee eights not good 98 is
what he played King bee 7 is the obvious
move how does white win a queen here
winning a queen is good if you're taking
notes winning a queen is good and this
is a tactical trick not really a
strategical trick rook a7 skewering the
king and queen and Knight b5 now is
Boris Gelfand going to see it is he
going to fall for that
No so golf game play Knight b8 and now I
was complaining and complaining and
complaining how bad his a 5 moves was
and that's why then again King a 7 king
bee 7 was this for the same reason the
only other legal move that makes any
sense is
night after d7 he resigned instead and
now I have many ways to win as the
computer will agree I was going to play
Bishop takes e5 he could throw this
check and if he wants that's we could do
that he wants now he has some issues for
example Queen takes Bishop what's the
best move for white highly recommended
Queen takes d7 bait that's the best move
and if you move your queen away because
you don't want to lose your queen like I
don't know here now you can meet several
ways most people like to sack their
queen for some reason so Queen d7 and
mate if you don't like to sack your
Queen because that's the kind of person
you are then you can play whip takes
Knight and then meet this way so instead
of all that horrible stuff happening and
there's other horrible stuff I could
have done but that's what I was planning
on doing he resigned hooray
if you don't like allowing rook takes
pawn shack because you don't like being
checked then you can play rook takes a
night and then rook takes Knight check
if you want to win that way you could
anyway you want there's so many ways for
whites to win that he resigned alright
so remember don't castle into checkmate
unless yeah but there's a much fun your
answer to that unless you're playing me
then then castle in the checkmate I like
to
you